[Music]
desperate attempt news submitted by Eric
Alvaro you know what's a desperate
attack when it's 2 a.m. and you still
don't got anybody you talk to at the
club that's true and you talk to anybody
and try to get a phone that's the
scariest time to be a girl walking alone
oh [ __ ] desperate I used to live in
Hollywood like Hollywood Hollywood and
like Hollywood Boulevard you know and if
I was just walking around cuz if I used
to go to improv shows on Hollywood
Boulevard at iOS and if I would walk
home after the shows but it would be
around that hour where the people were
getting out of clubs and I would just
get so rounded by single [ __ ] dudes
like hey where you going where you going
where you going like you got a man we're
gonna see where's your man like oh my
love where is he where's your man why is
it Gary
it's like he's really you're outnumbered
and you're just like I'm trying to get
home but I would always bring a hoodie
just try to like damn I don't know what
that feels like
well you're not that you're not so
utterly sexy they can tell you're sexy
through your clothes even through a hook
go but you're go around a bunch of
desperate dudes at 2:00 a.m. all right I
got it I got to know what that feels
like oh it's gonna boost your ego a lot
I have when I was like really
the probably feels like walking into a
construction site and I was getting up
that's a stereotype and it's true no
it's very yes sorry a guy emailed 246
Nicole's
trying to find the one he met the night
before oh now you don't go to this
university that's like Oh in though it's
hard to find love I get it isn't that
weird
no I get I'd be so flattered really like
if I liked it
please don't let go Thanks what if you
don't like it you don't like I feel
flattered but then like once we talk and
then I'm like no no thanks and he leaves
me alone I'm like cool like Drive he has
if he has like a really like where do
you live where's your glasses
if it's like kind of like soccer I don't
know you take notes stalkers anyone
that's don't talk like that
anyone that's that obsessive I'd be
afraid of what if he what if he sent
like 246 really trillion miles like I
don't really care about this one or that
one you don't feel like dang I made such
a lasting impression on someone that
because I can't that's a narcissistic
wait a thing and I feel like humans that
are that obsessive to gating something
that they don't even know what the prize
is is weird no no he knows but he knows
the prize cuz he talked to her right but
that's just what you said he talked to
her okay tell me if I'm we ever had like
connection like right off the bat
well yeah it's called being horny no no
I'm talking about like an actual connect
it
yeah like when I first met my best
friend I've had that but okay so so in
the very beginning yeah I would think
that there's this because my my
imagination is great you know I'll be
thinking like all this oh those be
awesome we might get married and all
that stuff right but reality is everyone
comes with negative [ __ ] and baggage and
all those things right so it's almost
like I want to see all that [ __ ] and see
if I can deal with that no but you know
I'm saying like you meet someone and
like it doesn't have to be the opposite
sex like I've had this like I sang with
my best friend where you meet them and
you're like holy [ __ ] like I feel like
I've known you forever and like it just
could you just gel and it meshes and
you're just like we can talk for hours
and this is sick like there's nothing
there's nothing weird yeah that's cool
but I also think it's [ __ ] crazy to
look for every single Jo in the school
so you can [ __ ] meet them again yeah
but it's kind of sweet if you like them
like if I found Nikki in the night like
yeah like if your conversation was
nauseous and it was like oh my god and
somehow I didn't get his number yeah I
would definitely do that yeah I think
that's awesome tell me if this is weird
many years ago probably ten years ago
I was at some bar and I'm sitting there
and I was talking I was I saw this girl
from Creston look at me and then she
looked at me twice and I'm like okay I'm
gonna say what's up yeah yeah so then I
was talking to her and then I just
wasn't thinking cuz I was thinking a lot
about I'm stressed out at work and I was
about to have a very bad day the next
day so I wasn't point thinking it
through so I was talking to her inviting
with her grading on stuff and then she
had to go and she's like oh well I have
to go who's great talking to you and I
was yeah you to see around whatever and
I didn't like clothes I never did that
before
if I did I probably have that feeling
like I [ __ ] up I gotta come I got a
cup like know exactly I had to settle I
just settled many years later no no but
you dodged the bullet no but it's weird
the weird part is okay so I went on
Craigslist did a misconnection response
been great but did it work did not work
I think that's awesome because like
because at least for me it's so hard for
me to really connect and drive with
people that once it happens I'm like
this is [ __ ] sick I got hold on
depends on this guy's track record is he
sending 200 emails every girl he meets
cuz he's so [ __ ] infatuated or he's a
normal guy and this girl literally like
made that kind of impression then I
think it's it's different yeah we need
context yes the ass [ __ ] that
are like this for every single girl that
they meet yes and that's what I'm
talking about that's what I'm worried
about because it's like there's a lot of
people out there that swears it's the
one [ __ ] obsessive if I was a woman
I'd be afraid of that I'll be like what
happened that would be afraid too if
that was crazy right so what happened so
this took place so this this dude whose
name is Carlos he decided to email all
of the Nicole's and the Nikki's and like
every variation of Nicole at the
University of Calgary like every single
email
had a Nicole you just leave the C and
the K and then and the CK yeah and the
CK I in the CKY see Nicolette like he
was very thorough yeah yeah and so in
addition to students he also got faculty
and even associate Dean's on the list
and so he sent a mass email it said this
would you like to read this do that he
didn't do it nobody hi this is a mass
email to all Nicole's if you don't fit
this description then ignore and if you
are the one then and just don't want to
talk to me that's okay as well if your
name is Nicole and you're from Holland
and you think niche is depressing then
text me his number
I'm Carlos by the way I'm the guy who
took you and your friend home last night
so Carlos from the Netherlands okay if
he took them home he knows where she
lives what the hell is he doing yeah
well okay so he's saying that he got her
number but that ended up being the wrong
number maybe so then that's when all
these other people they're like well
maybe she didn't want to yeah yeah he's
like no no she gave me her number
doesn't make any sense well that's why
he was like well if you don't want to
talk to me and that's cool but it's he's
like here you know I am attempting to
connect with you yeah so then all these
are calls like there are some saying
like should we reply that we're all the
real Nicole yeah and like they're just
like you know they ended up really
clicking a lot of these Nicole's these
equals our best friends now
karlof is scholarly okay here's a
picture of all the Nicole's right now
they're all together right they have a
big ol party this no that's that's what
you do every time you always take the
thing down you sure yeah
no no but I'm saying like you think I'm
not gonna do that because guess what I
have right here
no way
[Music]
[Applause]
Carlos is in the corner amazing viral
because the girl she said she ended up
tweeting this photo and says some dude
emailed every new pole at USC to try to
find the girl he met last night and I
listened you UFC
oh um um uh si si Oh instead they formed
a girl gang and I'm legit dying at you
they also created a Facebook group
called a Nicole from last night that's
why it clicked a lot of them are getting
together and like they're actually
forming like you know real other groups
are when I first made my myspace um I
think at that time there was just very
little Bart's brand only this guy he he
messaged me and he put me he added me to
the bar group and there's only eight
parts in that that's cool good talk so
several white guys and how's it going
the only Asian dude I don't know any
Asian Bart's this all does have a happy
ending though so the real Nicole emailed
all the poll the actually she need a she
in the club she sent a Facebook group
message board post girl wall but if
she's like is Carlos here cuz if he is
I'm not here yeah how do I hang but not
with Carlos so she sent hi fellow
Nicole's I'm the exchange student from
Holland who brought home by Carlos last
night and things that in each is quite
depressing don't have in you of feed
email so didn't get the beautiful email
myself but the powerful network of
Nicole's helped me get in touch I would
love to meet all of you sometime in the
future and so John Carlos
you went to my narrative oh please
so much ended up saying is that since
she just moved here whatever it like she
doesn't she never got the chance to
memorize her number correctly she
actually accidentally gave them the
wrong number that's sweet yeah so they
don't connect and they're married now
and they have babies exactly that's what
happened show me the picture I don't
have a [ __ ] you should always give it a
shot and go after what you want yeah
that's a great unless you do that every
time then you're a [ __ ] creep are
they dating I'm not sure I just know
that she really did try to give him the
number there's a fine line between sweet
and stalking it's a cool episode of a
show yeah it's not bad
yeah that's not bad yeah as an episode
yeah I enjoy it like how I Met Your
Mother it's like one of those episodes
oh yeah
and now there's like a cult of Nicole's
yeah Nicole Nicole hey Nev you said that
you're not part of the Nicole girl not
because I feel like I'm part of it
because because of my name is Nicole the
name is part of it by proxy so you're
not part of it isn't it Cole the the
name and then Nikki is kind of like a
like it's a good nickname yeah okay it's
like how Bill is short for William oh
yeah yeah or Richard and dick yeah
Richard and add all these mine's like
the first syllable your name is the most
popular name honors I think my name
Nicole I think it's the most used and
baby name ever
it's the Nikki is the most popular
stripper name well not for sure but I
think I'm a hot girl when I think of
Nikki yeah I thought them I would think
like the most popular name in the world
would be Indian Mohammed wasn't it that
I was thinking of here in the u.s. I
don't think it's like John or Michael or
some [ __ ] you guys want to test what is
y'all like cuz you know that that term
regular Joe yeah my cat's name is Joe
what now you spell it Jo you're Jo Jo Jo
Emma Olivia
Ava Isabel Sophia no no that's right now
no it says a thousand the most common
name about America see Muhammad right
most popular girl in America that's the
list that I said oh that's the most
current oh yeah Emma
Elizabeth Olivia yeah I told after the
most current celebrities
see Emma Stone Olivia mine yeah you
don't saying come I don't know any of
those
how about potato chip you don't know no
I don't know any Sophia's so yeah I feel
like there's so many Jennifer's and
Jessica's I knew something in high
school my sisters in geography yeah
there's a lot of celebrity Jessica's and
Jennifer's oh yeah yeah yeah that's true
there's a million Chris yeah yeah yeah
who's your favorite celebrity Jennifer
uh say like Aniston I like Jayla like
Jeff wait Jennifer Lawrence yeah yeah
like Doug
JLo j-law Jake JLo she's my part
[Music]